okay good um yeah thank you chairman
for the introduction and uh i want to
thank the organizers
for um put together this very nice
workshop and for inviting me to give a
talk here
uh yeah in in several
of the previous talks we learned that uh
tensor product states uh are very useful
to uh
classify um various phases of meta
and uh and in my talk i mainly want to
focus on a more
practical or like applied aspect i want
to show how we can use
tensor product states to derive various
order parameters that help us to
detect phases that emerge in the
presence of certain symmetries
ah and in particular i just have a
kind of two topics that i want to cover
in the first part
i want to mainly talk about symmetry
protected topological order in one
dimensional systems
where i want to begin by uh remind you
of
the um classification of these kind of
phases in fact
there's a complex complete
classification of these phases
and then i want to show uh how we can
derive
relative relatively kind of a simple
order parameter
that we can just calculate or
potentially measure um to
detect these phases um um starting from
some some hamiltonian that we are
looking at
uh and in the um and the second part i
want to talk about so-called
symmetry enriched um topological order
yeah i think have not heard about so far
but the main idea is that we um start
from a another system that
exhibits topological order and then it
turns out that um kind of
more complex structures can arise when
we have
symmetries so and then i gonna
show how at least for a certain set of
these um
orders we can actually um detect them
quite nicely
i'm starting from from tensor product
states and also we can derive some
non-local order parameters however i i
think i'm not gonna
be able to get into this okay
let me now start talking about the the
first of these topics
namely um i want to talk a little bit
about
sbt phases
in one dimensional systems
so and i first want to uh draw just like
a schematic
phase diagram where we have here some
parameter one and maybe here i have a
parameter two
and we now think about that we can tune
this parameter in the model
and first if in a one-dimensional system
we do not have any symmetry
so we have a system that is completely
unsymmetric it's just some random terms
um we already know that there's only one
phase and we know this from a number of
uh
recent works by uh norbert and also
so there's only one phase and i'm not
explaining exactly what phases are
because there's like uh this has been
covered in
a number of different talks so in
particular um
we we just um can just move to
everywhere without closing a gap
good so so now let us just put symmetry
into a system so let's say that the
hamiltonian that we are looking at
has a particular symmetry so it could be
just a z2 symmetry or
sup if you end symmetry some some more
complex symmetries
uh first of all we can now have like
certain phases
that break symmetries so this is like a
symmetry broken broken face
i mean this is a phase that we would for
example have in a simple transverse
field icing model
where we can now tune the transverse
field and we can have a transition
between a trivial paramagnetic face
that has the z2 symmetry and we can
actually tune into a
ferromagnetic face say where the z2
symmetry is spontaneously broken and
then we know from london's theory of
phase transition
it's not possible to go from here to
here without undergoing a phase
transition
and most importantly like at least for
this talk
it's easy to detect i mean to say that
we want to do a numerical simulation
of such a model or maybe a measure of
material that undergoes this transition
we know that we can just measure the
magnetization so the magnetization
that's the expectation value of the um
of sigma z say and then we find it zero
here and it's non-zero here
and that helps us to just uh um kind of
figure out where we are
where we are in the phase diagram and
what the system is doing
uh and then there's another class and
this is the class i want to talk about
these are the so-called spt or like the
symmetry
protected topological phases so uh
in this spt phase we actually find that
the ground state
will have the same symmetry as the kind
of trivial or the kind of the
paramagnetic phase here
so that would render this kind of local
order parameter useless so if we just
measure all kind of local quantities
like magnetization etc
we wouldn't see any difference between
these phases we would see that the gap
is closing
but we're not sure this we are running
into a different phase or just
accidentally having some closing of the
gap good
and this is what i want to focus on now
like
come up with some ideas um how can we
actually detect these phases so say
we have a hamiltonian and our task is to
um
to map out the phase diagram and i'm
going to show what kind of
expectation values we can calculate or
what kind of quantities
we can calculate to uh um to put a label
on this phase and in this
this is kind of very related to the very
first talk um we heard by um
bruno this morning monday morning it was
um good and just to motivate it a little
bit i want to start by looking at a
concrete example and this is sort of
the so-called holiday in phase
which again has been mentioned various
times during this these four days but i
want to just reiterate it briefly
and the holiday in phase shows up in the
s equals to one heisenberg chain
um and in particular this is a gapped
phase
and for future reference like when i
talk about phases and uh
phase diagrams and whatever um i would
always assume that
we're having gapped phases so i'm not
touching any gapless face here
we have a gapped phase and
no no symmetries are broken
so in the traditional picture this would
be just a maybe a
simple paramagnet because we don't have
any um broken symmetries
um however um this particular phase
or like um states in this phase have uh
have some
interesting properties so in particular
if we um
just diagonalize the hamiltonian on a
ring so we just
assume periodic boundary conditions we
find a unique
you find a unique ground state
on a on a ring
however we find that the ground state is
four-fold
degenerate um on an open chain
good uh and again this what i'm telling
now has been mentioned before
we can understand this using a
uh like a different model which is
related
to be adiabatically which is
adiabatically connected to this
heisenberg chain and this is the
so-called aklt model
so the physics or the nature of the
ground state
like the physics can be nicely
understood
i'm using the
so-called akl t model it's for f like
canada liebentasaki
and uh the the model is just simply a
sum
over all sides and we have just the p i
p i plus one and this does the projector
onto the spin two state on the bond
and we can also just easily write it in
terms of the um spin
spin operators so this is just the
heisenberg model where we just add a
cube a by quadratic term
now now we can um and then the the
nature of this ground state is the
following and again this has mentioned
before
that um each of the spin ones um we
split up into two spin one halves so we
have like sides where we have
this is like a spin one side here and we
split it up into two spin one halves
and in the ground state um we find that
the
um that the
it's been one house yes you said
different color maybe
so this bin one half are now forming uh
singlets with the neighboring side so
whenever i draw now like um this shape
this is just this singlet so this is
just one divided by square root of two
times uh up spin down spin minus down
up spin okay so and
uh from this simple cartoon picture we
um
and understand that the ground state is
gapped so
whenever we want to uh kind of
if you just break if you just break one
of these thinglets we have to
pay the energy that it costs to break
one of these thinglets
so that's a ring and we find that
there's a unique ground state so we
didn't really have to think how we
arrange these singlets so there's a
unique way of doing it
ah but now let us look at the open chain
so we just take this ring and we just
break it open
and with this of course we have to break
a singlet and
then we get the following picture
where we have now here again our spin
one half degrees of freedom
and these are now forming signals
so here we see that at the i didn't draw
it very
clearly but the story is bigger um
so here we have uh some
some half integer spin degrees of
freedom sitting at the edge
of our our chain and
and this is now exactly the um giving us
the
let me just write it down so we have now
the s equals to one half
edge spins uh it spins
and these are causing now a four-fold uh
degeneracy
good and uh
and that's already some i think very
remarkable feature because
we're having now a model where the
elementary degrees of freebie or like vm
the um the building blocks that we have
are us
integer spins so we have spin one things
that we're building our
model out of however we're having now a
kind of a fractionalized spins
sitting at the edges so here there's
been one halves and in fact
um this might look like a mathematical
um game to play however
um these edge spins also have been
observed experimentally so there are
certain materials
that can then a good approximation
described by
integer spin chains and if one dopes
these systems with non-magnetic
impurities
so which corresponds to basically just
breaking up these chains
one can observe these spin one halves in
these systems so this is uh
actually real good and uh
and this is now actually one example of
a pretty
big class namely of the class of these
uh symmetry
protected topological phases
and after kind of just introducing this
this example i want to
formalize this now a little bit um
so so if we have now an sbt phase
we assume now that
we have a certain symmetry which can be
uh whatever
kind of symmetry we like to think about
and
the hamiltonian and um also
the the ground state have uh the same
symmetry uh
uh group and uh
what we're gonna find and i'm gonna
elaborate on this a little bit
is that these um spt phases
are then characterized
by kind of symmetry fractionalization
i'm going to tell what this
is
and in particular we assume that we have
a linear representation
of a symmetry in the back
and we have a kind of a projective
representation
uh representation
at the edge
so what i mean by this like uh um we
have now if we just um
take this example again and we um use a
symmetry
and then uh for this model we could use
uh um
kind of um kind of some element groups
like which are part in the su-2 symmetry
of the system or like any subgroup of
this as
z2 cross e2 etc so we just act
now um like have a product of
of of some element of our symmetry group
and we act on this on the
on the on the entire segment and uh
um then we find that um the
edge degrees of freedom transform under
some
uh projective representations right so
so these u here are now the projective
representation in this case
it's easy to see we have uh in the bike
as i said we have
integer splints so we have spin ones so
these are linear representations of
maybe the spin rotations and here we
have half integer spin reach
half integer representation of the
rotation group at the boundary
good so this is maybe the characterizing
feature
of spt phases here good
ah good i gotta mention now many times
it's word projective representations
um let me just uh briefly remind you
what what what i mean by this
so if you have a projective
representation
representation
and the projective representation is
basically like a linear representation
of a group
modular modular phase so
let us now assume that we have g h and k
are elements of a group g
and we have now certain multiplication
rules
for our elements so if you just multiply
g
times h is equal to k then we find
that if we just multiply the
representations u g
times u h is equals to e to the
i and now we have just a we get a phase
vector
times uh uk if this one is identity we
have just a linear representation
if we have now these um this phase
vector this is a projective
representation
and then and i think this is a question
that um isaac sure
asked himself like more than 100 years
ago the question is like if i just write
down
some uh kind of if i choose particular
phase factors here
um can i actually now just um kind of
continuously change the phases
to actually um lift this projective
representation to a linear
representation right i mean
um and uh he found it you can't
depending uh in a certain scheme that we
can use to classify these different
projective representation
we can only uh transform particular
phases that are in the same class into
each other
so and um in the modern language i mean
i think back then
this very united st now this is
like in equivalent and equivalent
projective representations
are classified
by the second homology
so h2 of g over u1
good so so we have to calculate this one
and from this we can actually now tell
um whether um the the the representation
is a projective one or
something that can be just lifted to a
trivial one
oh they can be different i mean i can
give you an example actually now um
or two examples um
let's um because now we can actually
already kind of
from from this approach we will to be
able to do the following because if
someone gives us a hamiltonian we can
just look at the symmetries of that
hamiltonian
and then we will be able to answer if
there is a chance to have an sbt phase
or not
and for this let us start we someone
hands us a hamiltonian which has just
the
simple zn symmetry like for example the
z2 symmetry that we have
in the um in the icing model then it
turns out
that there's actually um um there's no
non-trivial non-trivial phase
um and we can see this sort of easily we
just know we have uh in
in in this group we have as a generator
just um r r is now just the rotation
of uh by 2 pi over n
uh and if we just uh write down we can
just write okay we know that if
r to the power of n is equal to the
identity
uh then we get here because there's only
one element we get only one
one one possible choice that we could
have the face namely
that u r to the power of n is equal to e
to the i um one phase times the identity
uh however here we can just easily um
see that
no matter whatever phase we choose here
we can just get rid of it
we can just uh define another u tilde
which is just e to the i or e to the
minus i
phi divided by n and we just made it to
a
linear representation so so here we
don't have any chance to find a
any spt phase in a one-dimensional
system if however we use a slightly more
complicated one
like z2 cross z2
we find that there's actually um two
two inequivalent
um representations
and uh the way they can do this like in
uh
the z2 cross c2 this corresponds
actually to
uh the rotation of some object about two
orthogonal axes
so this is the symmetry of uh of a
featureless book
uh and the um
so we have like a rotation about x
squared
uh and about u z squared is equals to
one
so with this we can now actually fix the
the phase vectors
of ux and uz however we have like one
other because the rotation
about the x-axis and the z-axis and this
commute so it doesn't matter which one i
would do first
so we have u u x times u z
is equal to uh plus or minus uh uz
to ux so um here we actually see we have
two
inequivalent uh projective
representation and uh
this cannot be undone so if you have
like either
um ux times you z is either
you you you x and u z are either
commuting or anti-commuting
so this is now the way that we can
distinguish um
these two phases so what have we
achieved so far for this
we actually now can tell uh based on uh
previous works that are from from that
are not done by many mathematicians
what kind of symmetry can give us like
how many different
projective representations and also we
basically now know
what kind of labels we can put so we
could say that we just go here and then
we say well
here we have maybe a plus phase or like
we could call it like a
phi equals to zero phase and this is our
phi equals to pi
phase so now we can just put labels on
the different uh
spt phases uh but now we want to come to
what i promised that we just
want to do something more applied so the
question is uh
if we have now some hamiltonian how can
we actually extract this information
so how to detect
sbt order
good in particular i want to show you um
how we can just write down some sort of
a non-local
order parameter that is doing this for
us
uh and and here i'm gonna um kind of
actually um being like a little bit
close to what we heard in the first
lecture by bruno
and particularly i want to advertise a
very similar idea
namely that
so so so here we see that um we were um
in order like the kind of characterizing
feature of these spt phases
where the edge spins uh and the nice way
is actually do the following now we just
take a system that is infinitely long so
we actually don't have any edges
but now we actually create some sort of
artificial edges using a schmidt
decomposition
gives kind of access
two so-called artificial edges
um and there is no following we have now
our um
like infinite chain
and we just um do a perform a by
partition of our chain
into a left part and a right part
good and now we can just write down our
wave function
for this system as being a sum
of alpha equals to 1 to infinity
of some schmidt values lambda alpha
times
phi alpha left alpha
right no
and uh yeah these which states are like
orthogonal
um
good so so we write down a schmidt
decomposition of a state
and uh in principle like now we are
doing a schmidt decomposition of a state
that is uh infinitely long to the left
and to the right
however um and this has been i think
discussed also in
may talks before that for um for
for for the ground states of one
dimensional
uh hamiltonians one for for one
dimension and gapped hamiltonians
we know that instead of summing here
from one to infinity
we actually capture most of the
information in the wave function
by only summing from here to uh i don't
know
just to a small number chi right so we
just uh most
almost the entire information that
contained in the wave function
is in a few of these schmidt states
there's a few largest one right like for
this i assume that i have shot them
according to the site i just
uh assumed that um they are just
sorted this way oh the other way around
okay late for everyone
okay and then i can just cut them off
and
uh and that's quite remarkable um
and this is uh the the reason why um
mps are working so well in one dimension
system
so what we find like for one-dimensional
systems
um
well this is i understand that's always
but it's
that you can sum up on it for a small
constant
well for for an infinite system this is
is definitely true for
for gap systems and if you have
a gapless system like and it's infinite
then we don't get away with it
i mean like if if we have a critical
state we actually have
to to sum over infinitely many stages
together a very good approximation of
the state
i mean just i think at least the picture
i don't the cartoon picture i have and
i'm not one of those
true is that if i have a critical state
uh so
so if i if i plot now here the i sort my
lumped
alpha and and i sort them according to
their size
for a critical system i will find
something like this so then i can
happily just truncate it here without
losing
uh information
for a gap system uh and for a
forget so this is a gift
but for a for a gap in this system
yeah i think they are basically i would
assume that they are flat and
basically zero everywhere so no matter
where i cut i will always cut
away most of the stuff from the wave
function
i'm not sure there's i mean i took this
basically from a work by uh
color breezer and lyft favorite where
they write down some distribution
function of these and
that distribution function as a function
of the correlation length
actually goes flat if we kind of if the
correlation
goes to infinity and this is at least
the cartoon picture i
have of what's happening good
but this we're not thinking about this
we're thinking about getting states good
uh yeah so so only um
only say high states kai and this is
like you assume like much smaller than
infinity for practical purposes um
states um contribute
to yourself significantly
and this gives us that uh rise to the
fact that we can like nicely approximate
these um the ground states of of
of local and gap hamiltonians
efficiently
using uh matrix product states so so we
just now
try to use matrix product states and in
particular i want to use the
so-called canonical form
and i'm using the notation that i
actually learned from giffor's
paper
and in fact we just write down the um
amplitudes now
of the um wave function uh i don't know
right again and and so on so it's like
an infinite state so basically we have
infinitely many indices here
and we express this one
as the following form
and it's good to be here so i can just
write this kind of form
because it showed up many times before
like using these diagrams that are very
useful
uh and uh here we have now the following
form which i've been
we've seen many times before like here
we have the um kind of the
the physical degrees of freedom of the
matrix product states and here we have
the um kind of the virtual
um degrees of freedom and that this goes
like on to
to infinity and the
the the um this form that i've chosen
here
the following like here these um lambda
these are the diagonal matrices that
have
the kind of the schmitt values on the
diagonal
the schmidt matrices and the
matrices or the rank three tensors gamma
here
they relate the local bases and the
schmidt bases down
to each other and i like this form very
much because of
the following because um like if we have
obtained our state in this form so if we
just
use a numerical algorithm that spits out
this particular form of our matrix
product state
it's really easy for us to um to get the
schmidt states
right because the schmidt states uh like
or the amplitudes of the schmidt states
um like i one to i n
let's say that here we do the schmidt
decomposition between side
i0 and i1
is just simply given by
so
final one so we just have our matrix
product state and we just
uh we can just erase like one half of it
and we just have here like some open
index alpha and then if we just multiply
the rest
we automatically get our schmidt state
so we just multiply our matrices
and then we have directly access to um
all the schmitt states and that would be
very useful
and because of this orthogonality
relation that we have here for the
schmidt states
we actually find the following nice
identity i don't know if it's visible
from
somewhere but if we just uh
multiply something like this
times the identity this is just the
identity
and we can see this here because i argue
here that the schmidt's eggs are
orthogonal
if i now just multiply this with the uh
with the cat
that is um and using this orthogonality
uh relation i i find this identity here
and the same is also true for
for the left so that we will use this
section later on
good
let me now come to
yeah how to extract the
information about what kind of page we
are in
so and here i just use now some results
that
were derived earlier by uh um perez
garcia
so let us now assume that we have a
state
um site that is symmetric
under
um like a product of gi
right um so this is now just i have like
some locals like um some some for
example g called the spin rotation like
rotating has been
about the x-axis and we apply this to
every side
um and then we know that the um wave
function is invariant under this so it
just changes only by a
by a state and then we know that if we
now
take our matrix gamma and
we just apply now the g to it then
the transformation is given by u g
times gamma times u g
dagger okay
ah and the matrices
are they called
and these are now exactly the projective
representation i was talking about
earlier
so because um in in in other words like
kind of using this analogy here
we actually find that um the matrix is u
so so these these indices here are
exactly the indices uh
kind of enumerating the schmidt states
so
this is exactly the representation of
our symmetry
in terms of the edge mode so in terms of
the um
the schmidt states so these
ug are the
projected representations
symmetry and uh what i've shown here now
in uh
in some more detail for kind of symmetry
that does product
of on-site symmetries we can actually
derive same results
like similar
um for inversion
like for inversion symmetry um
we just go from
um transpose the matrices so then we
just uh
just go from exchange left and right so
it's just like
mirroring the um the chain and also for
uh time reversal symmetry yeah that's
if you might actually have to do an xbox
one
uh on the physical index well we could i
mean like we can't have like
a combination right wait i mean this is
not equal i mean what we find
i mean maybe this is what i'm saying we
can use the same thing so which meaning
like that
gamma transpose is equal to
u i don't know inversion times gamma
times
and this is what i'm saying so so we can
like if we just do inversion
like this would correspond to inversion
and uh
then we can just do a similar argument
here but we
instead of applying a group element here
we just invert it and express it using
this kind of page transformation
um if i if i require that my state is
like also in the uh in the canonical
form i think it's a transpose
here
calculation that shows that this worked
similar but
maybe we overlooked something i wasn't
better on this by now
at least for all practical calculations
that i did it it worked this way
and for time reversing symmetry um we
find that
gamma j is
uh
so so here we just do a rotation by uh
around the y axis and we take the
complex conjugate of the
of the matrix good
and what i want to show now is that we
can get these
matrices u here or the representation
directly by diagonalizing the
kind of a kind of a generalized or mixed
transfer matrix
so the uog uh can be
directly called paint
by finding
the dominant
eigenvector
of the generalized
kind of transfer matrix
in particular well with t t g
and uh let me just show show how how i
can derive
this so we take now our
matrix product state and we just
multiply only part of it so so this
again
is now represented at a matrix product
state representation
of our schmidt state and here we have
now our gamma
gamma lambda gamma lambda
and we apply now a symmetry operation to
it like g
and now we can use
this identity here and we find we can
now express
we just basically plug this one in and
we find that uh
everything just uh oopsie
cancels except at the
last bond like here
so we have already kind of isolated this
guy here and now we can just
multiply the the cat
and we can do this on both sides
but now we can also use the identity
that i have shown before so then this is
just a ug
times the identity
right and what we see here
this one just corresponds to multiplying
uh
this this object and again and again so
if you're just multiplying this matrix
again and again
all that's going to be left eventually
is the dominant eigenvector
and this object here is the kind of a
generalized
transfer matrix like t g of alpha alpha
prime
and beta beta prime
okay so
and again and if we have now
done this
so so so so basically um like just
coming back to the kind of practical
application so if we have now used uh
some algorithm that uh maybe um dmg
and we have now obtained our matrix
product state
we just need to construct this matrix by
sandwiching our symmetry operation
into this object and construct a matrix
just by reshaping this object we just
diagonalize the matrix find the dominant
eigenvector of this matrix
and the corresponding eigenvector is
immediately our
our our kind of projective
representation
of the symmetry so this is comes
basically for free
so if you have done dmrg that
information is
is all there and once you have now uh
obtained your
um the the representation of the
symmetry you can then basically just
read off
what kind of phase you are in you can
just read off the label
so for example for z2 cross c2 you just
want to calculate the um
the commutator ux uz times u
ux minus 1 times
uz minus 1 and uh
this one is an actually plus or minus uh
chi
good uh depending on which face you're
in a chi
again being the dimension of your of
your matrix or the number of states that
you keep in your dmig code
and for inversion
we just find that the trace of u
times u star so this is slightly
different but in a similar reason we
just find
that because for if we have a system
that is inversion symmetric we can just
distinguish the two phases depending on
whether u is a symmetric or under
symmetric matrix
so this is plus or minus one and the
same for time reversal
so then we have like again same thing
good so so from this we can now actually
just directly um
uh read off what kind of face we are in
and uh
one yeah
like two times into another
um here we i mean we just take the um
the two
like we have i mean the mall that back
then we we
applied it to was a mall that actually
had this particular symmetry and then we
are
calculated for this and yeah i know my
question is that why do you get
finite too
we we started like you mean like where
we stop here with the finite group or
why are we
getting all the ugs for my group right
yeah i mean this can be anything i mean
you can just
that depends on the physical system
you're looking at i mean you can also
have
an infinite you can have maybe su 2 or
but then the size of this group is the
number of symmetries right
say you want to do like a complete like
if you have like a model with many
symmetries then you will have like
to look at many symmetries to to figure
out
for whether for a particular symmetry
you're having uh
different i mean there's very spaces you
can look for
yeah but if you if the group is infinite
does it mean you're continuing too many
phases
um actually i'm or or maybe i am just
i'm not completely wrong
or maybe i am on the ground well i don't
i mean that's in short i mean we have
particular symmetries and if you have
combination of symmetries you can get
like
extremely many different um phases yes
but uh for for example you want to start
with a continuous screw
as long as it's compact the comology
loop is fine
yeah this is like you can just look at
the proof tables and see how many
projected representations are like
what the homology classes are
so different this is fine right there
are only two two different classes right
so their case we have infinite symmetry
but
for continuous symmetry but you only
have kind of many cases
is this in practice i mean if you try to
do this near critical point
does it get do you get subject in single
um well maybe you can just give some i
mean
i think it's pretty robust i mean this
gives you some numbers like if i for
example look at the uh
um there's been one model
in in a bike in a uh with a single
ionized isotropy
i can go extremely near the critical
point
we already kind of see kind of finite
high effects and it still
still works but there's actually also
some sort of warning like if one has a
system with an extremely long
correlation length and uh um
well if if you can for example um are
not able to tell from your exact
organization or from your
dmrg simulation if the system is getless
or gapped
and you just nevertheless um just
calculate one of these other parameters
and you neglect the fact that the
dominant eigenvector is not
one but it's maybe 0.99 you this might
be on the wrong
track i mean this is a good thing i mean
one like when you just diagonalize the
transfer matrix you really want to make
sure that the dominant is
is exactly one like up to machine
precision and
uh and then you can trust the results
if if you find something slightly
smaller than one
it's it's dangerous because you might
actually be in a in a directory space
and you don't need to import the
symmetry at the level of the nps no
no that comes i mean the submissions
come
maybe the previous question was you
haven't really explained
why you only need to look at the second
commonology and not so you can compute
ug but then you only look
which is projective representation and
then you figure out
which clutter to which classes you can
figure out to his class it belongs
right yeah we haven't really explained
quite why that is the only thing you
would want to look at
oh that's why i mean what i want to show
here is right now that we can actually
put labels and then we know
these two phases will not be
adiabatically connected like i can just
say
i look at um i don't know i just speak
randomly like some symmetry that i find
in my system calculate um
the homology classes and then i can tell
okay these phases cannot be connected i
think i have a pi face and a zero phase
there's no way that i can go
electrically from one to the other one
um the fact that if i find now two
phases
and i say i just exhausted all
symmetries in my system
and i um calculated them all the
chromology classes for those
and i find the same labels for state
number one and state number two
actually there's a theory by noble truth
and also by uh chenchia
who showed that then there's actually an
adiabatic path between these two
if one can show this using matrix
product states that you can just
construct the paths
connecting these two ways
does this answer the question yes
yeah good
well there oh i think time is uh passing
very quickly
um let me now just very briefly at least
uh kind of pose a problem for the second
part um
in terms of the um kind of symmetry uh
enriched
topological order
here let me just start like in a similar
way as i did
for the sbt phases it's correct that
there's about two five minutes left
for 10 minutes okay so i have a little
bit more time good i always started late
okay um again i can now draw like a
phase diagram as
uh as before where i just have now some
some parameters and um let me just again
first start by having no symmetry in the
system if there's no symmetry
um we actually find um still a
distinction between phases which are
severe
and we have kind of topologically
watered
faces so for
for for making this distinction we don't
need any symmetries
and this has been shown within several
talks
um but now um and then this is kind of
even without symmetries as uh as i would
say it's so rich that we are don't we
don't really understand it i mean at
this moment we can't really
we know that they are for sure trivial
phases for logical order phases and
chiral phases
but maybe there's much more i don't
think that they have any claim of
completeness at this level
at least not that i know of and now
we add symmetry to the system
and then again we can have a distinction
between trivial phases
and kind of symmetry broken phases
then also in two dimensions we can have
symmetry protected phases such as
topological insulators
etc but one thing and this is what i
want to focus on is we can actually um
um have like a richer structure on these
topologically ordered phases
so say that uh they're just to pick up
on some example that we've seen before
we could have the um the turret code
like the z2
topological order and we find that if we
kind of enforce certain symmetries
that the topologically ordered phases
actually are like this
in this case maybe the tory code order
actually splits up into
record code order a and touring code
quarter b
and um only as long as the symmetry
symmetries are present
um the phases are not connected if i
just get rid of the symmetries
um i can actually go around from here to
here
okay so let us now
assume that we have some topologically
ordered
state with
some symmetries and again assume that
the symmetry of the state is now the
same as the symmetry of being
informative
good um
and let me now just simply draw some
some pictures um to
illustrate my what i what i was thinking
about here
so so this is under the face space but
this is now our our system
and uh in terms of a little like a
kind of topological order i just want to
think of uh
some sort of a soup of loops and these
um
loops are made out of something that i
don't necessarily need to
to specify here however that i
want to show here now is that the um
the system is kind of symmetric
um under um some
kind of kind of some symmetry uh g that
we applied to the
entire system and uh and oh before i
cannot move on i would say like what i'm
talking about now it wouldn't be um here
no it will not be complete i will only
be able to
detect particular like a certain class
of
symmetry and which topological phases
not all of them but for this particular
class that i want to look at
i assume now that we have a system
that's built out of a kind of elementary
building blocks we assume that the
objects transform
symmeters which are symmetric under a
particular symmetry group
and they form according to a linear
representation
good so this is now the the vacuum the
vacuum cannot think of uh
the soup of these um these loops so for
the tory code
model for example we just think of terms
of the um loops formed by up spins
but now we can have
excitation so we have like anionic
excitations in the system
and the thing is now that now the
anionic
excitations they transform now
according to some fractionalized
fractionalized symmetry
and the particular class that i want to
look at
would be the one where the kind of
different
representation can again be classified
by h
g of u1
good and uh the
uh i'm running really short in time so
in order to to shortcut a little bit
i um that's going to say in
a few words the the general idea that i
want to follow and then just
draw like just write down a very
simple toy model and where we actually
can just by looking at the model
we actually already can tell what kind
of face we would be in with respect to
this
kind of classifications so the idea
would be the following and again i can
just refer to
uh quite some work that has been uh
shown
during the past few days to how to
detect them
like these um sct
these kind of referring to those that um
we can actually distinguish here
um and the idea is now the following
first of we heard about the um
that there's this topological degeneracy
topological uh degeneracy
which means that this was which i think
by by shao gunvan and also by others
that if we just take a system with
topological order and we put it on a
torus
that we find that the ground seat is
degenerate and the ground city generally
is actually equal to the number of
other particles that we have in the
system so topological generality on the
toros
on a tauros uh corresponds to the number
of different kind of anionic quasar
particles we have
okay so now we have to have a system so
if you just diagonalize our hamiltonian
we find uh degenerate ground states
in particular we have now like a degree
of freedom how we choose these um
these states and uh there's a particular
choice to do this and these are called
um
use the minimally entangled states
and to get these we just take our um
our tauros and we now form a bipartition
of the taurus into uh in a sort of
non-trivial way
we just cut our trolls like this into a
and into
b so this is like a non-trivial
bipartition
of a system and it turns out and this
was shown by uh
frank chang and ashwin vishwanath and
others and
before that i think also by uh some
other people
that um that if we
if we kind of do this partition the
entanglement entropy
between or the entanglement between the
left and the right part depends actually
on what kind of state we choose so
so there's actually preferred bases that
we maybe want to look at and this is the
one
where we just minimize the entanglement
and if we choose
um these kind of states then the
um ground states that we find like the
minimum entangled states they are also
eigen states
of um wilson loop operators that
wind around the toros so so these are
now
eigenstates of the wilson loop operator
also eigenstates
of wilson loop operators
group operators being like parallel to
the cut
and this means that the um these kind of
and if you just to this particular basis
we have some sort of a well-defined kind
of anionic um flux
going around the um this taurus
and if we now take this
this torus and we just do like our
schmidt decomposition say
of this torus
like this we would find that these
states
actually have a particular father
particle type
sitting here at the edge so here we have
now uh
the further particle say of type a and
this gives us now
access to the quasa particles and uh
the idea that i were to propose but i
think we are running out of time
is to do the following we just instead
of looking our editors
we look at a like an infinite cylinder
like which is very long
that we can map to uh that we can then
map to uh
um to back to a matrix product state and
do the schmidt decomposition of a
similar way and then we can
have this cartoon picture where we have
now an anion of a particular type
sitting here right so now we have like
an anion here of type
type a and this will again like in a
similar way as before
give us access to the projective
representation so we just
do the following we just construct now
sort of a generalized transfer matrix
for uh
for our kind of uh long cylinder and
then we can just
read off the um the projective
representations again
so and then this kind of tells us what
kind of
sct phase we would be in okay yeah with
this i
um thank you
a simple example is the following we can
uh let me just remove this
okay the example at least well the
simple example might be the fraction
from the ball state where you just have
fractional charges
um but the model that would fall to this
category where we can use the second
chromology to distinguish them would be
for example a model where you just have
the honeycomb model
honeycomb lattice um
and this model is constructed in such a
way that we have the spin one bosons
sitting on this lattice maybe for
example some
here's like s equals to one bosons
and we say that well whenever we have
bosons
these bosons like to form an akit chain
right so so that and that state this is
a state that we can just um
represent with a three-dimensional paths
so
whenever we have bosons they form aklt
chains and now we see that if we
um actually create oh and then the
ground state is going to be the
equivalent superposition of all those so
if you look from the distance it looks
exactly like a z2
liquid if however we just break open
some of this chain
we see here that we have just half
integer
spins associated with the electric
charges
in the in this z2 model and in fact
um then in this way it's like very
similar in spirit to the um
kind of um rv state on a cargo mile
lattice
because there are these on excitations
corresponding to those also carry
fractional spins
more questions